die brisant wie gefährlich die
internationale Sicherheitslage ist
konnten wir erkennen beim
Raketeneinschlag in Polen mein Gast bei
mir war vor anderthalb Jahren schon mal
bei mir Professor Karl Schlögel einer
der renommiertesten osteuropa-experten
das was wir jetzt beobachten ist eine
unglaubliche Sensibilität aber wir haben
auch eine Beobachtung die vielleicht
eine Wende anzeigt wie beurteilen Sie
die Situation nach der Rückeroberung von
Person
wenn man die Bilder gesehen hat von
kerson dann bedeutet es dass die
Bevölkerung unglaublich glücklich war
dass die Russen weg mussten und dass die
Ukraine die ukrainischen Truppen in die
Stadt gekommen sind dass die Herr Sonne
vielleicht wieder zurück können und das
ist ein großartiges Sieg an denen man so
schnell eigentlich gar nicht glauben
konnte und es zeigt wie stark eigentlich
die Ukraine ist wir wollen ja auch über
die Ukraine noch einmal sprechen unter
dem Aspekt dass sie gesagt haben ich
muss mir immer ein Bild vor Ort machen
sie sind in der Ukraine unzählige Male
gewesen sie kennen die Ukraine sehr gut
dieses ich will mal ein Bild machen was
ist das im Augenblick für ein Bild bei
Ihnen
das Bild ist ungeheuerliche Gaststätte
die man kennt Plätze die man kennt
Straßen Parks Denkmäler
dass sie gebombt werden und zwar in
einer Weise dass die Städte aussehen wie
sie nicht mal nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
ausgesehen haben man kann das Zentrum
von charaki heute kaum wiedererkennen
Mario Paul jeder weiß dass diese Stadt
ist dem Erdboden gleichgemacht worden
Theater sind zerstört worden Museen
sogar Städte die ganz weit weg von der
Front sind Lemberg wird von Raketen
getroffen
aber es ist eigentlich nicht nur das
Raketen einschlagen sondern dass die
Lebensgrundlage dieser Städte zerstört
wird und was bedeutet es eigentlich wenn
man die
Energieversorgung eine Millionenstadt
eine Stadt die fast zu groß ist wie
Berlin von der Bevölkerung
was sie nicht mehr mit Strom mit Wasser
mit Licht
versorgt werden kann was bedeutet es ist
bedeutet dass diese Stadt
unlebbar wird dass man raus muss und das
ist die Vernichtung der Lebensgrundlage
einer Stadt wir haben einen Brief mit
unterschrieben der Ukraine helfen diesen
krisenwinter zu überstehen da haben mehr
als 70 Osteuropa Forscher
Wissenschaftler Schriftsteller
unterschrieben das ist so ein bisschen
das Gegenstück zu dem was wir am Anfang
von einigen intellektuellen gelesen
haben in Deutschland es gibt immer noch
diesen Konflikt zwischen denen die sagen
wir müssen etwa bei den
Waffenlieferungen konsequent sein müssen
das liefern was notwendig ist damit sich
die Ukraine verteidigen kann und denen
die sagen wir müssen sofort den
Verhandlungen eintreten
da hat sich ein bisschen was verändert
auch der eine oder andere ist überrascht
über das was die Ukraine geschafft hat
unglaubliche Dinge passiert es ist
inzwischen ein voll entfalteter Krieg
mit der Zerstörung von Städten der
Infrastruktur der Erzeugung einer
Hungersnot eine Fluchtbewegung ja 14
Millionen Menschen sind vertrieben
worden im Land und jenseits der Grenzen
und werden nicht kapiert wer nicht
kapiert dass das ein vollentfaltete
Krieg ist und der glaubt sei immer noch
nicht klar wer angreife wer Verteidiger
wer Krieg führt und wer Widerstand
leisten wer das nicht kapiert hat der
muss sehr weit von der Wirklichkeit weg
sein und jetzt geht es einfach darum
jeder kann sich sehr vorstellen wenn der
Winter kommt selbst in unseren
Breitengraden es wird sehr kalt was
bedeutet es für eine Großstadt das ist
dunkel wird man kann jetzt die Bilder ja
schon sehen dass es kalt wird wie halten
Städte wir halten die Bewohner dieser
Städte das aus und eigentlich ist es
eine ganz elementare Einsicht die
Ukraine braucht Unterstützung um über
diesen Winter zu kommen und sie braucht
vor allem Waffen um den Himmel zu
schließen aus dem die Drohnen aus dem
die Raketen kommen und
das ist so elementar und und klar und
also es gibt so etwas wie
Nachhilfeunterricht
in den in den letzten in den letzten
Monaten
zu verstehen dass ein Krieg in mitten in
Europa stattfindet zu dem man sich
verhalten muss und das heißt auch dass
bestimmte Vorstellungen und
Illusionen dass man die hinter sich
lassen muss und sich entscheiden aber es
wird ja immer wieder gesagt eigentlich
sind die
Bemühungen des Westens nicht ausreichend
um mit Putin ins Gespräch zu kommen und
nicht möglicherweise auch zu einem
Waffenstillstand zu kommen
also es gibt ja es gab ja Vorschläge
ganz am Anfang selensky hat einen
Vorschlag gemacht zu Gesprächen sie sind
kategorisch zurückgewiesen worden und
bis heute bis auf den heutigen Tag gibt
es die Forderung nach Kapitulation es
gibt überhaupt keinen kein Anzeichen
dafür dass Putin darauf verzichtet die
Ukraine in die Knie zu zwingen und wie
soll ein eine Verhandlung stattfinden
wenn die
Städte gebombt werden wenn Hungersnöte
ausgelöst werden übrigens nicht nur
keine sondern auch weltweit wie soll man
mit einem solchen Partner überhaupt
verhandeln selinski hat auf der
Konferenz auf Bali ihr gesprochen
gute ist gar nicht gekommen das zeigt
auch dass er im Grunde feige ist seine
Position der Aggression und seine
völkermörderische Politik zu vertreten
er hat er hat
geschickt der sich immerhin noch
herausgenommen hat auf dem Balkon in
Bermuda Shorts aufzutreten ist für ein
Zeichen das Labor auf der Außenminister
Russlands sich in einer derartigen
Montur zeigt mit iPhone in der Hand mit
westlichen Attributen ich glaube dass es
ziemlich gut zeigt dass diese politische
Kultur
Putins der putinführung heute einfach
darauf pfeift überhaupt noch die
elementarsten Regeln auch im
diplomatischen Verkehr die elementaren
Regeln des Anstands und die Einhaltung
der Form zu bewahren es ist eine
Demonstration
es ist uns egal was wir über uns denkt
wir machen wir machen das was wir für
richtig halten und das kann man auf
allen Ebenen beobachten es gibt eine
Verwahrlosung der Sprache es gibt eine
eine Verwahrlosung und Zerstörung der
diplomatischen Formen die es ja immer
gegeben hat und die ist auch in
sowjetischer Zeit gegeben hat also
jemand wie gummiko und er kommt ja aus
dieser Schule die haben bestimmte Formen
bewahrt und die Zerstörung der Formen
der sprachlichen Formen der
diplomatischen Formen des
überschreitende Grenzen das Gehörte
sozusagen zum Politikstil dieses Neo
imperialistischen Russland ist es eine
Demokratie auf den Balkon des Hotels auf
Bali das ist eine Demonstration
wir machen was wir wollen
können Sie das eigentlich noch denn wir
haben ja jetzt erlebt dass die
Europäische Union die NATO die
europäischen Länder die USA in einer
ganz bemerkenswerten Weise
zusammenstehen und das wird nicht nur
des Krieges der Verteidigung wegen getan
sondern auch deswegen weil man deutlich
machen will wir verteidigen auch die
westliche Demokratie dass demokratische
und liberale Gesellschaftsmodell ist das
eigentlich auch das Ziel die Zerstörung
dieser Idee durch Putin
naja sie die Putin Leute sagen ja immer
dass es ja nicht nur um die Ukraine geht
sondern es ist der Kampf gegen den
kollektiven den globalen Westen das ist
eine Kampfansage an uns das eine
Kampfansage an Europa an die Europäische
Union an die transatlantische
Gemeinschaft das ist vollständig klar
und er spielt sich ja auf aber er hat es
nicht gewagt in Bali aufzutreten
sozusagen der Wortführer all dere zu
sein die Rache nehmen am globalen Westen
und an der Globalisierung und so weiter
wie kommt das denn bei den Russen an
kann er damit verfangen im Gefühl der
Russen die sich vielleicht auch zu
großen Teilen in ein Reich zurücksehen
was eine große Weltmacht ist was auf der
ganz großen Bühne mitspielt
die Russen die Russen leben seit Jahren
und zunehmend und besonders in den
letzten Jahren und in der Zeit diese
offensiven Kriegsführung unter einem
Schirm der staatlichen Propaganda eine
permanenten Bearbeitung der Bevölkerung
den eingeredet wird dass Russland ein
Krieg in der Ukraine führt gegen Nazis
und das das eigentlich ein
selbstverteidigungskrieg ist unter
diesem
damit wird die Bevölkerung bearbeitet
und die meisten Leute insbesondere die
ältere Generation guckte diese Fernsehen
Nachrichten und guckt die Fernsehshows
und wir machen uns gar keine Vorstellung
was dort im Fernsehen abläuft das sind
nicht nur die Nachrichten die die
bizarren und grotesk sind sondern es ist
eine Unentwegte Bearbeitung in
Talkshows in den nebenher einfach so von
davon gesprochen wird dass man durchaus
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen kann also
sozusagen ein Ton angeschlagen wird dass
eine
Kriegsdrohung besteht und das Russland
angegriffen wird und diese diese
Vorstellung des Russlands sich
verteidigen muss obwohl es in Wahrheit
an ein Angriffskrieg geführt hat das
soll sozusagen den den Konsens innerhalb
der Gesellschaft aber funktioniert das
nachdem junge Menschen eingezogen werden
an der Front sterben in der Ukraine die
Familien zunächst einmal mit großen
Geldbeträgen ruhig gestellt werden
sollten aber doch in der Bevölkerung
schon sehr sehr viel von dem Krieg
ankommt wir haben ja am Anfang erlebt im
Februar im März im April dass der Krieg
irgendwo ganz ganz weit
stattfand dass man also in der
großen Brust im großen russischen Reich
eigentlich davon wenig merkte aber das
ist ja da angekommen inzwischen es ist
angekommen aber eine Gesellschaft ist so
wie soll ich sagen träge des Landes so
riesig bis dort eine Nachricht ankommt
und ein wirklich trifft
das ist das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen und es ist sehr interessant dass
es zunächst dort angekommen ist wo an
der Peripherie also gar nicht in den
Hauptstädten die ja in gewisser Weise
privilegiert sind sondern an der
Peripherie das war ein Jakutien das war
ein dagistan wo die Frauen auf die
Straße gegangen sind und sagten wir
wollen nicht dass unsere Männer unsere
Freunde unsere
das in den Krieg die sind auch die
Straße gegangen und es hat einzelne
Tower einzelne aber immerhin tausende
gegeben die auf die Straße gegangen sind
mit einem Plakat oder
sozusagen mit einer Aussage jedenfalls
sie sind in gezielten chirurgischen
Operationen sozusagen aus dem Verkehr
gezogen worden abgeurteilt und so weiter
und die Regierung denkt offensichtlich
immer noch dass sie diese Situation
kontrollieren kann aber sie war zum
Beispiel nicht darauf gefasst und das
ist und ich muss sagen ich habe das vor
vier Wochen auch nicht mir vorstellen
können dass
300 bis 400.000 Menschen Männer im
wirfähigen im arbeitsfähigen Alter über
die Grenze gehen ja in kilometerlang
Staus Finnland Georgien Mongolei
hunderttausend Menschen sind mit den
Auto mit dem Fahrrad mit dem E-Bike zu
Fuß dorthin gewandert und ich meine sie
sind das war keine Widerstandsaktion
aber es war wir wir tragen diesen Krieg
nicht mit ja Russland verliert ja
eigentlich das was Putin immer erreichen
wollte Putin wollte wieder das große
starke Sowjet reicht zurück mit auch
einer wirtschaftlichen und
technologischen Bedeutung in der Welt
das Gegenteil passiert jetzt die
Intelligenz ja geht aus Russland raus
vor allen Dingen auch die jungen
Menschen gehen nach Israel in die Türkei
wo auch immer hin weil sie da auch eine
Zukunft sehen
gleichzeitig geht die wirtschaftliche
Situation um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen
den Bach runter in Russland er erreicht
genau das Gegenteil wie stark ist er
denn jetzt in einer Zwangssituation
ja diese Brändle in der geht ja schon
seit vielen Jahren also wo sozusagen die
gebildeten die
tatendurstigen die Aktiven Leute aus der
Landes getrieben werden ein ungeheure
Verlust an sozusagen humanenkapital und
modernisierungspotenz Putin hat
überhaupt kein Interesse das muss man
jetzt einfach so sagen dass dieses
Russland ein modernes Russland wird er
ihm genügt ist wenn er seine Rohstoffe
Öl Gas jetzt auch Getreide
verkaufen kann und
sozusagen er profitiert von diesen
Experten ein modernes Russland mit
selbständigen Leuten selbstständig
denkenden Leuten die sich um das Land
kümmern das interessiert ihn über aber
das geht doch wirtschaftlich schief denn
er lebt ja gerade bei der Energiekrise
die wir erleben wir versuchen jetzt sehr
schnell das klappt mal besser oder
weniger alternative Energien stärker
auszubauen und zu diversifizieren sowie
die Europäische Union das will das heißt
verschiedene Anbieter von Energie
auszuwählen und nicht mehr auf die
Pipeline zu vertrauen und damit geht
doch die Zukunft eigentlich einer reinen
energieverkaufsaktion aus Russland dem
Ende entgegen ja das sehen auch alle
denkenden Leute aber die diese Clique
sie braucht ein modernes Land nicht sie
braucht nicht mal ein Volk das muss man
sich vorstellen es ist ihr gleichgültig
ob hunderttausende und inzwischen sind
es Millionen die auseinander gehen und
es ist offensichtlich die
der Macht Erhalt der Kampf um den macht
Erhalt ist diese Figur wichtiger als das
Schicksal Russlands aber wie lange kann
er das Durchhalten er ist ja jetzt immer
stärker unter Druck oder sitzt da jemand
im Kreml der das alles um ihn herum
nicht mehr mitbekommt natürlich gibt es
diesen Druck aber der Druck wird
zunächst mal und den erste Linie vom
Widerstand der Ukraine ausgeübt darauf
war er nicht gefasst das hat er nicht
kapiert weil er nicht versteht was
dieses was ein unabhängiges freies Land
ist er glaubt wirklich in wenigen Tagen
die Kiew zu besetzen die Führung zu
köpfen und das Land
fertig zu machen das ist missglück und
es ist ihm wieder nicht glücklich es ist
in den Kämpfen in don't was und jetzt
wieder in
auf darauf war er nicht gefasst und das
zeigt und dass er trotzdem seinen Kurs
fortführt ja also die jüngsten schweren
bombatte Maus die schwersten seit
Oktober die zeigen dass er weitermachen
will und offensichtlich bereit ist auch
Russland mit in den Abgrund zu ziehen
aber wir fragen uns ja immer wie lange
kann er das denn durchhalten sie sind
nun kein Militärstratege
auch da könnte man ja fragen wie lang
ist das militärisch durchzuhalten aber
wie lange ist das im Land durchzuhalten
mit den Russen ja ich bin kein
Militärexperte aber auch die
Militärexperten waren
verblüfft und mussten sich belehren
lassen dass diese große russische Armee
einfach ein in verschiedene Hinsicht ein
Haufen ist der nicht funktioniert man
hat Zerstörungskraft indem man Raketen
Drohnen und so weiter loslässt
Zerstörung aber ein Krieg zu führen ist
diese Armee offensichtlich nicht
besonders in der Lage sie laufen
auseinander sie können versorgt werden
die Familien müssen in Rucksäcke und
Schlafsäcke mit auf den Weg gehen und
das kann man übrigens merken es gibt
Familien vor allem in grenznahen Gebiet
in bilgerode in Rastow Gebiet die ihre
die fordern dass die ihre Söhne nicht an
die Front geschickt werden weil sie
nicht einmal die minimalste Ausrüstung
haben und das
also dieser Krieg ist auch ein Lehrstück
darüber dass man große Mächte auch
überschätzen kann und dass diese Armee
Schwäche ist als man gedacht hat was
nichts von ihrer Gefahren nimmt weil
natürlich
diese Führung dann zu anderen Mitteln
greifen sprich bombardi
nukleardrungen möchte ich noch mal
sprechen mit Ihnen aber zunächst noch
mal die Frage hat er damit auch den
Willen des Westens falsch eingeschätzt
der Ukraine zu liefern dass die Ukraine
braucht denn wir haben ja jetzt
den Eindruck die Ukraine bekommt was sie
braucht und das heißt ja nicht nur die
Waffen sondern auch sehr viele
Geheimdienste Informationen die
Aufklärung funktioniert angeblicher sehr
sehr gut nicht zuletzt durch sehr sehr
gute Aufklärung der Amerikaner
das ist wahr natürlich ohne diese Waffen
wäre der Widerstand nicht möglich
gewesen aber das erste ist doch das ist
eine Armee ist die nicht einfach eine
Armee ist sondern die getragen ist von
der einhelligen Meinung und Bereitschaft
der Ukraine das eigene Land zu
verteidigen und in der Bundesrepublik
gab sie mal diesen Spruch von den
Bürgern in Uniform ja man muss sagen
dass eigentlich diese Armee und die
Freiwilligen Bewegungen die diese Armee
trägt und das Hinterland wo
Krankenschwestern Hochschullehrer und
was weiß ich
Theater Leute hinter diese Armee stehen
oder sogar in diese arme gehen ja und es
gibt auch Opfer ja
konzertdirigenten Theaterleute ein
Tänzer ein berühmter Tänzer der mit an
die Front gegangen ist hinter dieser
Armee steht die Bevölkerung der Ukraine
ja das ist ihre Stärke und deswegen
jemand wie Klitschko der Bürgermeister
von
von Kiew und natürlich selensky der
immer wieder sagt ihr werdet uns nicht
in die Knie zwingen das ist das ist so
aber sie brauchen Waffen um den Himmel
zu schließen gegen diesen Regen von
Bomben Drohnen und und Zerstörung
die
Eskalationsstufe die wir seit einigen
Wochen hören heißt atomare Drohung und
wir alle fragen uns
wie realistisch wie gefährlich ist die
wirklich
die Drohung hat ja funktioniert in dem
Sinne dass überhaupt wir uns mit dieser
Frage beschäftigen was das bedeutet und
was in dem Kopf von Putin und seinem
Zirkel losgeht also die Drohung die
eskalationstrohung hat ja funktioniert
man überlegt darf man jetzt Waffen
liefern ist das nicht eine Provokation
dazu muss man sagen Putin braucht keine
Provokationen er braucht keine Anlässe
er schafft diese Anlässe und deswegen
kann man nur sagen ist hat etwas mit der
Unterstützung der Verteidigung der
Ukraine und auch der Europäer zu tun und
hat nichts wie manche Leute glauben
etwas mit belizismus zu tun
die keine wünscht nichts sehnlicher und
ich glaube auch diejenigen die sie
unterstützen als den Frieden ja aber
nicht den Frieden auf Knien vielen
Frieden der mit mit einem Preis
verbunden ist den niemand und
wahrscheinlich auch wir nicht beheizt
sind zu zahlen und was diese Preis ist
das kann man ablesen an den Zerstörungen
an
ja der Zerstörung der Lebensgrundlagen
eines eines Staates sich ganz nicht
anders formulieren und die Probe wird in
diesem Winter sein
gucken wir mal auf Deutschland da gibt
es große Meinungsunterschiede über
diesen Krieg da wird sogar in einigen
Zirkeln darüber gesprochen dass er ja
eigentlich ein von den USA provozierter
Krieg warum sind die Deutschen zu teilen
so kritisch der Verteidigung der Ukraine
gegenüber es gibt ja auch sehr starke
regionale Unterschiede etwa in
Ostdeutschland wo die Ablehnung dieses
Krieges vor allen Dingen an der
Ablehnung auch der Amerikaner ist
also generell glaube ich kann man sagen
dass viele Leute die die
so denken einfach keine Ahnung haben was
eigentlich dort los ist und was die
keine ist die meisten Leute in
Deutschland haben ja die keine überhaupt
erst wahrgenommen
nachdem sie Kriegsschauplatz geworden
ist ansonsten im Horizont sogar von
gebildeten Leuten hat man auf Russland
gestartet hat
war der ganze Raum besetzt von von
Russland jemand vom Russland Kitsch
gesprochen ja ich meine das auch ernst
Russland Kitsch heißt dass man die
diese Erinnerung beschwört dass man über
die Kultur redet aber das was passiert
das ist ein Krieg gibt dass man das
ausblendet und dass man vor allem auch
wenn man schon von Schuld der Deutschen
spricht diese Schuld nie bezieht auf die
Ukraine auf Belarus die eigentlich der
Hauptschauplatz der deutschen Verbrechen
gewesen sind sondern nur auf Russland
und dieses als erstens die Leute wissen
meistens oder wussten lange nicht was
das überhaupt ist die keine das größte
europäische Land und es hat zunächst mit
CIA und Amerika gar nicht zu tun die UK
keine haben seit ihrer
ihre Unabhängigkeit seit der Orangenen
Revolution seit der Krim seit dem Maidan
sie haben für ihr Land für eine freie
Gesellschaft gekämpft und das ist keine
Inszenierung von irgendjemand von außen
das ist das ist das ist die Entscheidung
des des ukrainischen Volkes und was die
ost-west-differenz angeht also mir kommt
es so vor von den ersten Demonstrationen
von pegida in Dresden und so weiter wo
an Putin appelliert wurde
putin wird dort verstanden gewissermaßen
als der große Rächer also der ist den
Amerikanern dem Westen zeigt und der
sozusagen derjenige ist der Einspruch
erhebt und Widerstand leistet gegen eine
wie sie glauben eine missglückte oder
ungerechte Wiedervereinigung also er ist
sozusagen die Symbolfigur
die die aufgefahren wird um es den zu
zeigen und das hat mit mit Ukraine
Kenntnisse der Russland Kenntnis oder
eine
spezifischen und intimen Verhältnis zu
Russland nicht viel zu tun wir haben am
Anfang gesprochen über Shazam und die
Frage ob das ein Wendepunkt in dem Krieg
ist eine sagen wir mal diplomatische
politische Wende könnte sich ja bei G20
angedeutet haben China und Indien die
beiden haben eigentlich immer relativ
deutlich in den Anfangszeiten hinter
Russland gestanden da ist eine kleine
gewisse Distanz entstanden nicht zuletzt
durch den Hinweis darauf man müsse jede
Art von atomdrohung vermeiden
gibt es da einen kleinen
Hoffnungsschimmer das vielleicht
Russland so isoliert am Ende ist dass
man von russischer Seite aus keine große
Unterstützung mehr bekommt
das ist wahr das ist ein
bedeutendes Signal das
das sozusagen ein großes Einverständnis
darüber besteht das diese Atom Drohungen
verwerflich zu echten sind und das
rüsselt auf einen falschen Trip ist ja
auf einen gefährlichen tritt aber ich
möchte sagen das Spiel ist nicht zu Ende
diese Isolation ist nicht abgeschlossen
und komplett seine große Hoffnung ist
doch dass der Westen oder Europa unter
den Druck unter dem Stress
dessen was auf
uns zukommt
der Preissteigerung
Inflationsgefahr eine allgemeine Angst
dass man das bedient und damit spielt
und es wird Wahlen geben es wird und es
gibt ein Spiel mit den
sozusagen den Widersprüchen die
natürlich in der Europäischen Union
auftreten die Auftreten in Amerika es
gibt überall gespaltene Gesellschaften
und
und die Hoffnung war natürlich auch
dass die Wahlen in die Mitte war ein
anderes ausgehen als sie ausgegangen
sind nein das Spiel geht weiter und wir
müssen uns darauf gefasst machen dass
dass der Druck der Einsatz die
Mobilisierung auch ja ich meine in
Deutschland gibt es ja Parteien die
putinistischer orientiert sind ja also
Frau Wagenknecht bisschen zu der
Eltern Alternative für Deutschland sie
sind ja sozusagen für einen ein Modus
wie wenn die mit dem Putin Regime und
und erklären und verteidigen seine
Politik also das Spiel ist nicht zu Ende
wir müssen ich glaube wachsam sein und
auf alles gefasst sein und
auch der Krieg dort wird weitergehen und
die einzige Möglichkeit den abzukürzen
ist ist der russischen Armee Niederlagen
beizufügen und sie aus dem Land zu
treiben
wir hauen auf einer Lösung und eine
Lösung die nicht allzu fern in der
Zukunft liegt ganz herzlichen Dank für
die situationsschilderung und Analyse
von ihnen danke schön
[Musik]